[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nouvelle édition du sky
échos le récit de la vie des acteurs
économiques du territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines
nous sommes sur le site d'atos aux
clayes-sous-bois atos un des leaders
internationaux de la transformation
digitale
c'est un spécialiste des services
numériques du big data aux
supercalculateurs en passant par la
cyber sécurité
ils viennent d'inaugurer ce bâtiment un
laboratoire de recherche et de
développement dédiés à l'informatique
quantique et à la cybersécurité c'est ce
que vous découvrirez dans ce 19ème
numéro du sky et l'incubateur et
accélérateur de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines recherche de
nouvelles start up pour intégrer le ski
cube une campagne jusqu'au 28 juin
basée aux clayes-sous-bois le centre r&d
d'atos dédié aux cantiques et à la
cybersécurité vient d'être inauguré dans
les prochaines semaines les premiers
ingénieurs commenceront à s'installer
découverte d'une start-up implantée à
trappes rdi manager propose une solution
pour simplifier et rendre efficient le
management de projet d'innovation
[Musique]
oh
le site d'atos des clayes-sous-bois
s'agrandit avec un laboratoire baptisé
diane plus de 8000 m² dédié à la
recherche et au développement sur
l'informatique quantique et la
cybersécurité 350 collaborateurs vont
rejoindre ce site dans les prochains
mois ce sont des ingénieurs en
informatique et en physique quantique
pour en parler nous sommes avec nicolas
quintin chef d'établissement d'atos aux
clayes-sous-bois bonjour bonjour alors
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire en quoi
consiste ce site en fait alors vous êtes
ici au sein du campus des
clayes-sous-bois campus au sein duquel
nous sommes installés depuis près de 60
ans et pour lequel nous engageons et
nous poursuivons la modernisation de cet
espace avec la création de ce nouvel
environnement un bâtiment extrêmement
complexe tant par sa taille que par les
technologies qui seront développées et
qui justifie à ce titre là un
environnement technique très précis
c'est un bâtiment sur deux étages
exactement donc le rez-de-chaussée est
exclusivement dédiée à l'environnement
technique
donc on aura dans ces espaces qui l'a
près d'une centaine de biens
informatiques par exemple qui seront
installés différents laboratoires pour
nos ingénieurs qui ils réaliseront des
recherches sur le cantique et la
cybersécurité et vous retrouverez au
premier et au deuxième étage des espaces
dits plus tertiaires dans lequel
effectivement les collaborateurs seront
en capacité de poursuivre les recherches
qui le mettront ensuite en application
au rez-de-chaussée de ce bâtiment au
premier étage
allons-y
[Musique]
alors nicolas quimper nous sommes au
premier étage du bâtiment diane je le
rappelle c'est encore en cours
d'aménagement dans l'entièreté du
bâtiment alors est ce que vous pouvez me
dire qu'est ce qu'il se passe ici en
fait d'un au premier étage
donc nous sommes ici là très clairement
dans snow appelons les espaces
collectifs et se passe dans lesquelles
les collaborateurs retrouveront leurs
postes de travail et ensuite nous avons
ajouté donc sur ses 2200 mètres carrés
dans les étages une multitude des
espaces dits alternatifs alors bien
entendu plusieurs cafétéria mais
également différents types d' espace
pour se réunir et pour faciliter ce que
l'on recherche vraiment la création et
l'innovation
on retrouve bien entendu des petites
salles de réunion vous en retrouverez
deux plus grandes salles de réunion pour
les meetings plus important ils disent
que ce soit flexible en fait faciliter
l'innovation à travers la flexibilité de
l'organisation du travail et avec un
intérêt fort de faciliter la
communication les interactions entre
l'ensemble des services aucun service
n'est cloisonné de manière à faciliter
la circulation des personnes et par
défaut des idées on le verra après avec
arnaud bertrand il ya en plus des
informaticiens mais aussi des des
ingénieurs en quantique donc c'est aussi
sa facilité le travail entre les deux
domaines d'activités
exactement et vous verrez d'autres
espaces où on est peut-être davantage
dans un cocon londres une bulle de
silence pour pouvoir justement par
exemple passer deux trois heures sur un
livre extrêmement complexe les lier aux
cantiques et alors la collaboration
passe aussi par des outils un peu
particulier comme ce tableau en fait
exactement donc là vous vous trouvez
dans un espace dit bien entendu
alternatif avec des positions autres de
travail qui ont démontré effectivement
que ça faciliter les interactions et la
créativité et puis là nous avons ajouté
un peu partout sur sur laitages et
également au deuxième bien entendu ce
qu'on appelle des des tableaux mobile
avec un intérêt principal qui est la
possibilité de pouvoir rédiger et noter
les remarques et les points qu'ils sont
qui sont évoqués en réunion et la
capacité ensuite de pouvoir déplacer
cette ce mobilier pour pouvoir ensuite
par exemple le positionnés à proximité
de mon poste de travail est également
profité de ce mobilier pour créer aussi
une rupture visuel et acoustique
merci nicolas qu'un pas merci à vous je
rappelle que vous êtes le chef
d'établissement du site à tous ceux des
clayes-sous-bois et on va tout de suite
rejoindre arnaud bertrand qui est
directeur stratégie innovation big data
et cybersécurité pour atos
[Musique]
oh
et nous avons rejoint arnaud bertrand
directeur stratégie et innovation big
data et cybersécurité bonjour bonjour le
bâtiment diane est dédié à la recherche
au développement sur le cantique mais
aussi sur la cybersécurité d'abord
l'informatique quantique simplement
qu'est ce que c'est alors il ya deux
choses il ya le cantique dans
l'informatique et l'informatique
quantique dont le cantique dans
l'informatique ça fait des années qu'on
utilise des effets quantiques stade r d
effet au plus petit niveau de la matière
par exemple l'effet tunnel qui est à la
base des transistors donc en fait on
utilise du cantique dans l'informatique
depuis les années les années 50 les
années 70 dans les microprocesseurs
donc on a déjà du cantique dans
l'informatique depuis des années après
l'informatique son appel l'informatique
quantique qui effectivement une nouvelle
discipline c'est l'utilisation de
propriété infinitésimale pour faire du
calcul et en l'occurrence à se base sur
deux principes de mécanique quantique
qui sont la superposition et
l'intrication quantique
je vais pas rentrer dans le détail mais
grosso modo il y a deux principes qui
permettent effectivement de coder de la
donne et d'appliquer un traitement à
cette donnée qui est codée dans la
matière puis de lire un résultat et de
on va dire de retraités ce résultat là
pour assurer que ce résultat est fiable
parce que le problème dans
l'informatique quantique séquelles et
probabiliste ça veut dire qu'on a une
probabilité de pâlir la bonne zone
voilà en simplifiant c'est ça quelles
sont les applications concrètement à
quoi ça va servir
alors en fait il ya un certain nombre
d'algorithmes qui peuvent être
accélérées par du calcul quantique ça va
pas concerner tout donc on va pas demain
démarrer un opérating system un système
exploitation sur une machine quantique
par contre on a quelques algorithme qui
peuvent être accéléré donc on a des
algorithmes par exemple pour rechercher
le plus bas d'une courbe alors ça va
servir par exemple à faire des calculs
de risques pour des banques
on a des algorithmes qui vont faire
permettre de faire de la factorisation
dentier ça va servir pour faire du
chiffrement ou du déchiffrement de
données on a des algorithmes qui vont
permettre de faire des des replis ou des
calculs sur l'optimisation de chaîne
complexe ce qui va servir en chimie qui
va servir ans dans la conception de
médicaments ou de molécules alors les
chercheurs et ingénieurs informaticiens
les physiciens qui vont être ici dans ce
bâtiment ont travaillé à partir des
premiers travaux que vous avez fait
puisque aujourd'hui vous savez simuler
l'informatique quantique vous avez un
outil qui le permet
l'objectif je suppose que c'est de
passer de la simulation à la
concrétisation finalement voyez alors
pour nous évidemment l'objectif est pas
de rester à l'étape de simulation ce
qu'on cherche à faire
in fine et c'est d'intégrer dans nos
super calculateur des accélérateurs
quantique au même titre qu'on a
aujourd'hui des accélérateurs graphiques
en plus des processeurs généralistes ce
qui nous permet en fait de d'extraire
les algorithmes qui vont être accélérés
par les processeurs graphiques ou par
les professeurs pratiquent à les faire
traiter là où c'est efficace merci
arnaud bertrand merci directeur
stratégie innovation big data et
cybersécurité pour le groupe atos avant
de vous parler d'une start up basée à
trappes un mot sur la nouvelle campagne
d'appel à candidature pour rejoindre le
ski cube l'incubateur de saint quentin
en yvelines va accueillir de nouvelles
start up pour rappel le ski cube vous
accompagne à travers un programme
d'incubation ou d'accélération
les porteurs de projet ont jusqu'au 28
juin pour candidater pour toute
information vous pouvez contacter
valérie carew à l'adresse mail ou au
numéro qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
et prenons maintenant la direction de
trappes pour découvrir une start-up son
nom rdi manager elle développe des
outils de management de l'innovation
rencontre avec son dirigeant kevin chief
enjoy
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour moi c'est kevin dit fin juin je
suis le célèbre manager une start-up des
technologies du numérique qui développe
une plateforme de management de
l'innovation à destination des
entreprises des universités et des
finances et de l'innovation
on est située dans les yvelines dans la
ville de trappes et nous sommes une
équipe de six personnes
[Musique]
et
notre activité consiste à développer une
solution pour aider les entreprises
innovantes à mieux gérer leurs projets
[Musique]
les fonctionnalités principales capote
et des managers
c'est le suivi des faits marquants dans
un projet et puis le suivi du temps les
deux piles par consulter les équipes
travaillent et chaque fin de semaine
ils reçoivent un mail d'une relance
automatique qu'il a dit ou fait
contributeur sur quels projets pensez à
mettre vos faits marquants de la semaine
si vous en avez r des managers appli
principal but d'apporter plus de
compétitivité et d'efficacité en
recherche développement innovation aux
entreprises innovantes
[Musique]
on s'est rendu compte que beaucoup de
pme et tpe avait du mal à bien gérer de
manière structurée l'actif de recherche
et développement en général on se rend
compte que les informations techniques
capitale se retrouve parfois de manière
dispersée
le management de l'innovation dans les
grands groupes se fait de manière très
sculptures et ses traits carrés un essai
un compte rendu des faits une diffusion
tout ceci avec une inertie qui parfois
peut affecter l'efficacité
opérationnelle des équipes r&d
[Musique]
je trouve que l'entrepreneuriat c'est
quelque chose c'est une aventure voilà
ces quelques pâles au goût de l'aventuré
laventure de réaliser de créer d'avoir
des idées et de leur donner la
possibilité d'exister et d'évoluer c'est
un pari c'est une aventure qui a du
risque mais c'est formateur
[Musique]
c'est la fin de cette émission
enregistrée depuis le nouveau centre de
recherche et développement du groupe
atos aux clayes-sous-bois merci de
l'avoir suivi émission à revoir en
replay sur notre site internet ou sur
l'application mobile
à bientôt sur tv 70
[Musique]